mick fanning ou d'effectifs et 3d n'est
accroche on rit devant alors pierre
forte et notre invité ce soir économiste
professeur à l'université du québec à
montréal pierre fortin bonsoir bonsoir
la pire récession depuis les années 30
est ce que l' approche proactive des
gouvernements est la bonne solution en
ce moment oui c'est la pire récession en
effet plongé ont été premièrement très
soudaine puis deuxième en profondeur
voire les chefs bientôt la réaction des
gouvernements évidemment c'est celle de
protéger la vie des gens éviter qu'on a
une conflagration aussi souvent table
que celle qu'on a vécue que nos arrières
grands parents ont vécu pendant la
grippe espagnole you santa il ya
cinquante mille canadiens qui sont morts
à l'époque le maintenant ce serait avec
la population qui augmente et 225000 que
ça vous de rezé
donc il n'ya pas de ses six essais il
fallait vraiment intervenir rapidement
puis donner les rênes à la santé
publique
serons-nous selon vous obligé de passer
par une période d'austérité
après tout cela pour rétablir l'état de
santé des finances publiques
non on ne reporte besoin de penser par
une période d'austérité c'est à dire
qu'il ya des augmentations importants
d'impôts des baisses ou des rats
lancement important de la croissance des
ventes comme ce qu'on a connu un 2014
2016 si au québec et puis dans bien
d'autres pays c'était encore pire au
québec
pourquoi c'est tout simplement que le le
montant qui va devoir être empruntée par
exemple par le gouvernement fédéral qui
devrait probable
a dépassé de 100 milliards de dollars
pour l'année 2020 2021 mais 200
milliards de dollars vont pouvoir être
emprunté à des taux d'intérêt qui défie
toute compétition dans les années 80 les
taux d'intérêt que les gouvernements
avaient payé sur leurs emprunts à long
terme mais ton de 10 à 30 ans c'était de
l'ordre de 10% à 15% et donc évidemment
si on avait à payer 10 à 15% sur 200
millions ce serait pas mal d'argent ça
serait 20 à 30 milliards alors que même
un pour ça tout ce qu'ils ont à payer le
gouvernement fédéral sur 200 milliards
ça va être deux milliards par année
alors qu'on sait qu'en temps normal les
revenus fiscaux du gouvernement fédéral
seulement de 10 à 15 milliards paradis
donc 2 millions sur dix ou quinze
milliards ça ce rapport énorme comme
bouchée avalée et à mesure que le temps
va passer on va constater que la
croissance économique qu'on espère
qu'ils vont revenir vont manger
le service de la dette supplémentaire
qui vont avoir été encourus à cause de
la caf 19 l'ex économiste en chef du fmi
olivier blanchard disait en entrevue à
rdi économie qu'il n'est pas convaincu
qu'il faudra stimuler l'économie après
la crise
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous qu'ils
à forte d'abord c'est important vous
parliez de t'intéresser que vous parliez
de vielles blanchard c'est un des
économistes la plus grande réputation
parmi les mecs macroéconomistes dans le
monde contemporain et en plus il ya un
doctorat honorifique de l'uqam donc il
est très bien associé chez nous donc
monsieur blanchard dit que c'est pas
impossible que la reprise économique qui
viendrait après que le
le virus a été vaincu qui a été matée
c'est pas impossible que même parti si
une bonne partie qui reviennent
d'elle-même de la croissance économique
et donc que la reprise n'est pas
tellement besoin d'être pour revenir
maintenant ce qu'il y a dit aussi qu'il
n'était pas sûr de cette affirmation là
que ce poids il se peut que les gens
ayant été sous le choc de du virus soit
très très très prudent dans la dépense
des fans qui vont avoir acculés en gros
pendant la période de combats extrêmes
contre le virus et par conséquent la
réponse qu'il donne est mitigé dans un
sens mais maintenant plus près de chez
nous c'est bien évident que l'industrie
la culture l'industrie du tourisme par
exemple l'aéronautique les voyages
aériens cetera
ces industries l'heure chez nous vous
êtes aussi probablement difficulté on
prendra pas nécessairement l'airpod
restaurant qu'on a manqué pendant le
fameux combat contre le virus
quelle leçon doit-on tirer de covin neuf
pour être mieux préparé à affronter les
prochaines crises mais ce que c'est nous
dit en fait c'est que on gère mal le
risque pas parce que on a deux méchants
gouvernement ou des gouvernements qui
sont au mi octobre les taux cia ont dit
des êtres humains est souvent les
risques ça nous apparaît un peu abstrait
et on y voit seulement qu'un le malheur
nous frappe
et puis l'on se dit oh mon dieu on aura
dû se préparer au je pense maintenant
comprendre ce que par exemple dans le
domaine de la santé il faut accorder une
place beaucoup plus importante à la
santé publique est la prévention des
monts par exemple j'en disais récemment
un article qui disait que presque la
moitié des décès
en amérique du nord sont dus à baby
faute une mauvaise gestion du risque la
peur des gens par exemple sur le plat la
mauvaise alimentation sur le plan de la
mauvaise conduite automobile le tabac
l'alcool les drogues etc donc et on n'a
pas fini de d'éduquer nos enfants par
exemple dans le domaine de la prise de
saines habitudes alimentaires de faire
d'exercice physique et total tous ses
aspects de de prévention lors de la
maladie vont enfin devoir il va falloir
qu'on mette plus l'accent là dessus et
la manière de la faire c'est qu'on est
des budgets ce qu'on appelle des budgets
protégés se faisait plutôt que chaque
année ça soit seulement le ou la
ministre responsable de la santé qui
décèdent que conte au tel ou tel budget
dans la prévention mais qu'on ait de loi
qui nous disent bien il faut que ce sera
au moins un tel show ce serait la même
chose par exemple dans le domaine de la
gestion des routes chaque année on a mal
investissions ne sous investis dans la
réparation noro de chez nous on se
retrouve avec des routes pleines de
trous et des mêmes des pertes de vie
quand viaduc de la concorde à tomber est
tombé et par conséquent il faut
j'appelle récent institutionnaliser la
clairvoyance institutionnaliser la
clairvoyance faire en sorte qu'on se
donne les lois qui nous protègent contre
notre négligence coupable de la bonne
gestion des risques évidemment la
prévention la santé publique doit être
une des premières préoccupations qu'on a
parce qu'actuellement ce qu'on a de plus
précieux c'est l'on vit bien pierre
fortin c'est toujours un plaisir de vous
écouter merci d'avoir été avec nous ce
soir au plaisir